apache cassandra is an open source nosql
distributed database
this beginner's course has four modules
the first three modules cover the basics
of apache cassandra data modeling the
final module covers practical
applications of cassandra
if you want a broad overview of nosql
databases you can check out the previous
nosql database course on our channel
this module will cover the basics of
apache cassandra data modeling upon
completion of this module you will be
able to differentiate between the
relational databases and an apache
standard database
recognize the basic terminologies used
in cassandra tables
explore cql fundamentals
identify how partitions primary keys and
clustering columns are used in cassandra
tables
observe the concept of replication and
consistency
upon completing this lesson you will be
able to understand how relational data
modeling concepts compare to those used
when data modeling for apache cassandra
now you will learn about some
differences between relational databases
and apache cassandra
the cassandra data model follows
cassandra modeling methodology while the
relational database follows the sample
relational model methodology
in cassandra modeling we think about the
application needs when building the data
model
since queries are the driving force for
this model those queries must be
conceptualized before data entry whereas
in a relational model entities are the
driving factor
in relational modeling primary keys are
used to ensure uniqueness of the
entities
in cassandra modeling primary keys take
on an additional significance
particularly in determining performance
on a large scale
in order for us to provide high
performance and availability on a large
scale cassandra uses a distributed
architecture
cassandra by default does not support
asset transactions or joins but uses
denormalization instead
cassandra does not enforce referential
integrity across tables
here's a sample of a relational data
model
this is one of many types of relational
data models
this model produces conceptual logical
and physical data models including steps
for normalization and optimizing the
data model
note that queries aren't considered
until the very late stages of the
process
let's now look at the apache cassandra
data modeling approach
here we still have conceptual logical
and physical data models but the
application workflow and inquiries are
considered earlier in the process
this analysis is incorporated early into
the logical data modeling phase rather
than waiting until the end of the
process
let's look at the difference between the
modeling approaches
in the relational approach we first
think about the type of data create a
data model based on the data and then
think about our application last
the developer can then make queries to
retrieve this information
in the approach followed by cassandra
the process is reversed
here the application of the data must be
decided up front in other words what
queries are going to be performed
that will dictate how your logical model
will take shape
once your queries and data model are
complete you can load the data into your
tables
relational databases are asset compliant
by default
acid is used to describe the
transactional behavior in a relational
database and stands for atomicity
consistency isolation and durability
atomicity refers to the integrity of the
database transaction either all the
statements in a transaction will succeed
or none of them will
consistency means that the data within a
database should comply with certain
rules
transactions cannot leave the database
in an inconsistent state
the new database state must satisfy
integrity constraints
isolation refers to the ability to
process multiple transactions at the
same time without interference
durability refers to the ability of a
completed transaction persisting even
after a subsequent failure
apache cassandra does not support asset
properties like most relational
databases
in database management both commit and
rollback can easily be achieved using
transaction logging when a single server
is involved
but when the data is spread across
servers in distributed databases like
cassandra the situation becomes tricky
the locking and coordination required to
ensure these two-phase semantics of acid
can cause severe performance penalties
however cassandra does provide atomicity
isolation and durability when performing
read and write commands on a single row
additionally it also provides something
called tunable consistency which can be
adjusted depending upon the number of
nodes which have to agree to execute a
particular read or write command
to understand tunable consistency let's
look at the cap theorem first
given by eric brewer this theorem talks
about the trade-offs in implementing a
distributed database
all distributed databases are primarily
tolerant to partitions hence the choice
is really between consistency and
availability
cassandra by default is an ap system
which means it chooses availability and
partition tolerance while sacrificing
consistency
however it does provide the option to
make the system more consistent by
sacrificing availability this is
referred to as tunable consistency
wherein the consistency of the database
can be adjusted or tuned by adjusting
the number of nodes which have to return
a read or write request
cassandra primarily operates under the
ap model because all data eventually
becomes consistent
one more point of difference between
cassandra and relational databases is
the support of joins
to recall joins are a statement often
used by relational databases to combine
data
a join statement facilitates the query
through the joining of data from
different tables
take a look at the example below the
join statement combines results from two
tables namely videos which stores the
details of videos and comments which
stores the comments made by different
users on the videos this is done by the
matching of video id as specified in
both the tables the database matches the
video id for each video and generates a
result
this is the output of the join command
the select statement in the given
transaction selects the column specified
from the output of the join command and
the where statement is the filtering
criteria
therefore the output of this transaction
only provides the comments of the video
titled interstellar
the basic requirement for a join command
to work is that the results from two
combined tables should be stored at one
location
however in distributed databases the
different partitions of data are stored
on different nodes hence joins would
have a negative impact on the latency as
the scale of the databases increases and
the random distributions become more
prevalent
unlike relational databases cassandra
does not support joints but uses
denormalization instead
denormalization ensures that all the
required information is confined to the
appropriate table without having to
perform joins
organizing data like this can duplicate
data in multiple tables which is cost
efficient and allows for faster
retrieval of said data while using
cassandra to organize the data the
developer can decide upfront what tables
they want their data to be in
in this example we have two scenarios in
which we want to access comments
first a video view where all the
comments for a particular video can be
viewed and a second a user view that
displays comments made by a particular
user
to support this two tables must be
created
the first table comments by video
supports the ability to access comments
for a specific video
here video title is used as a partition
key
the comment id helps in defining a
unique row in the database for each
comment
the second table comments by user
supports the same data but has a
different partition key
here the user id is used as the
partition key
note that these two tables reflect the
common naming convention we have for
cassandra tables we append by something
to the table name to convey some idea of
the query that the table is designed to
support
joins rely on referential integrity
constraints to combine data
let's look at this point of difference
between relational data modeling and
cassandra data modeling
ri refers to the relationship between
tables
a value in one table requires the same
value to exist in another table
if there is a user in the user by email
table then the user must also exist in
the users table and vice versa this
referential integrity is required
between tables such that a user is
either represented in both tables or
none of them and also requires for a
join to work properly
cassandra does not enforce referential
integrity because this capability
requires a read before a write
it is not considered an issue that has
to be fixed on the cassandra side
although it is a feature that improves
performance and accessibility it is
considered a developer prerogative
referential integrity can be enforced in
an application design but that means
more work for the developers
upon completing this topic you will be
able to
differentiate between the terminologies
used in apache cassandra tables
understand the different data types
available in cassandra
cassandra uses database terms that have
specific connotations in the context of
data modeling
the key terms are data model key space
table and partition
a data model is an abstract model for
organizing elements of the data
data models vary depending on the type
capability and purpose of the database
the type of the data model depends on
the capability of the database
for cassandra the data model is based on
the queries that you may want to perform
a key space is the outermost logical
container of tables
it stores tables and replication data
in other words it's a container for
replication
a table is a combination of rows and
columns
the tables are contained within the k
space
as a columnar database cassandra stores
data based on partitions
partition is a raw rows of data that are
stored on a node in the data table based
on the partitioning strategy
each row in the partition consists of
key and value pairs
cassandra stores and retrieves data
based on partitions
a partition is a terminology where you
can make or break the data model
a primary key is the most important part
of the data model
it does two things
first it guarantees the uniqueness of
the data and second it defines the
placement of the record in the cluster
this allows for easy access to the data
in the model
a partition key is the first part of the
primary key it determines where in the
cluster your data will be stored on
which node it will be stored
a partition key is a left hand column in
the graphic indicating one two or three
respectively
inside each partition there are rows and
columns
columns are stored locally and referred
to as cells in the table
a row is contained inside a partition
there can be more rows and they are
stored together on a partition
clustering columns define the order of
data within a given partition
the default sorting is in the ascending
order
upon completing this lesson you will be
able to explore the basic cql concepts
within an apache cassandra database
cassandra query language or cql is a
nosql language also known as not only
sql
let's learn about some basic cql
concepts including
building blocks such as key spaces
tables and the primary keys as well as
basic cql commands such as select
truncate alter table and source
the key space is a top level container
in apache cassandra to organize a
related set of tables
it is very similar to a relational
databases schema
cassandra key space defines replication
settings that describe how many copies
of a given piece of data are being
stored within a cluster
once you've created a key space in cqlsh
you may want to select the key space
that will be used for your subsequent
command
you can enter a use command followed by
the name of the key space
if you do not select a key space with
the use command you'll have to include
the name of the key space whenever you
reference the name of a table
this helps cassandra interpret your
request
let's take a quick look at the syntax
for creating a table
the code here shows the statements for
creating two different tables
remember the key spaces contain tables
and tables contain our data
note that every cassandra table has a
primary key
inside each key space is the table the
primary key clause is a unique
identification for each row within the
table
cassandra's primary keys uniquely
identify rows of data
in this example we see a uuid used as a
partition key to uniquely identify each
user in our users table
however a partition key alone is not
enough to ensure uniqueness of a row
it is the primary key clause as a whole
that determines uniqueness of a row
within a partition
the cql select command is used to read
data from cassandra tables
selecting all the rows of the table
using an asterisk notation causes
cassandra to perform a full table scan
this could be very expensive on a table
with a large number of rows
instead use the limit keyword to get a
subset of the rows
cassandra also supports a paging
mechanism which indicates specific
columns we desire to read by name or
uses the asterisks to indicate all
columns
cassandra also supports a couple of
built-in aggregation functions such as
the count function
for counts on larger tables you may want
to consider using the spark part of disk
analytics
another command you'll find useful is
the truncate command
this command causes all rows to be
deleted from a table while leaving the
schema in place
this command should obviously be used
with care as the data is removed from
persistent storage and you would have to
restore it from a backup to retrieve it
truncate sends a jmx command to all
nodes to delete ss tables that hold the
data
if any of these nodes are down the
command will fail while working with
cassandra you'll most likely encounter
situations when you'll need to make
changes to your table
this is where the altered table command
comes into play
you can change the data type of a column
add columns drop columns rename columns
and change table properties but you
cannot change the columns in a primary
key clause
here's an example code for adding and
dropping columns from a table
the last command is the source command
which allows you to execute a set of cql
statements from a file
to execute a source command you'll want
to put the file name in single quotes
cqlsh will output the results of each
command sequentially as it executes
upon completing this topic you will be
able to
learn about the basic concepts of
partitions table partitions partition
ordering partition distribution and
partition storage
to truly understand the data modeling
you must master partitioning concepts
partitions give you an indication of
where your data is in your data model as
well as in the cluster
we will go through some of these
concepts in depth
partitions partition keys composite
partition keys and clustering columns
here are two commands that can be
executed on a relational database as
well as on apache cassandra
in a relational world these queries
should work on a video table because of
joins
here common queries are title equals and
added date is less than
if you run this in a cassandra database
the output appears as an invalid request
this is because the partition keys
absent from the equality clause of the
search expression these commands fail
because joins are not supported
you've already seen the structure of the
storage engine in lesson two
this diagram demonstrates how the data
is translated from the storage engine
into a cql table
when used programmatically that is when
we select data from the table we see it
in rows and columns just like we use in
our application
determination of the partition key is a
critical step
if you look at this diagram closely we
have the primary key as the id
there is just one column in the primary
key
the partition key is always the first
value in the primary key
this module will cover the basics of a
cassandra data model
upon completion of this module you will
be able to explore the concept of
denormalization
and investigate collection counters and
user defined data types
upon completing this topic you will be
able to
explain how joints are used in
relational data modeling
relay the concept of denormalization
used by cassandra
you have already learned that the
relational data model supports joins and
apache cassandra supports denormalized
tables
here you see three tables named videos
users and comments
each table has unique information in it
this is a typical relational example
we're going to make all these work
together by running a join query to see
how they can be used in relation to each
other
join query joins two tables to work as
one
let's assume that you want to find some
comments for a particular movie
the first table titled videos store
details of videos and the second table
comment stores comments made by users on
all the videos
we need to find a particular entry which
has all the data collected from both the
tables
let's say we are searching for a comment
from the videos table
how do we access the comment from the
comment table if you just have the video
with us
this is possible using the join query
they are often used by relational
databases to organize data
the two tables shown previously are
joined and this is how the output looks
like
the tables are merged with the help of
the video id specified in both the
tables
that is how relational databases work
in the code the title is interstellar
the select statement in the given
transaction selects the columns
specified from the output of the join
command and the bear statement specifies
which values to select from the
specified column
now this can be used to do a join on two
tables and get comments for that one
title
this is how
rdbms or relational databases are
designed
in the output of this transaction we
will get the comments of the video
titled interstellar
that is how the relational databases
were designed to be used having multiple
tables and then using queries to merge
and bring outputs
you've just learned how the relational
data model works with joins
now it's time to see how cassandra works
without joins
let's look at these two tables closely
they look similar but the primary key is
different for both
in the first table comments by video the
video title is the partition key and the
comment id is the clustering column
and in the second table comments by user
the user id is the partition key and the
comment id is used as a clustering
column
these are the denormalized tables used
in cassandra of the same joins that were
used in the relational data models
upon completing this topic
you will be able to learn how collection
columns and collection types
are considered
understand how to create and use udts
learn about counters
you will now learn about some additional
data types supported by apache cassandra
for efficiency
these data types are collections
counters and user-defined data types or
udts
these data types simplify table design
optimize table functionality
store data more efficiently and might
even change the design of the table
completely
now you're going to learn about
collections
cassandra provides collection types to
group and store data together in a
single column
take for example a relational database
or a cassandra database to understand
this concept
consider that in a relational database
you have to group multiple email
addresses of a user meaning there will
be a many to one joint relationship
between a user table and an email table
but cassandra awards joins between two
tables by storing the user's email
addresses in a collection column in the
user table
each collection specifies the data type
of the data held
the collection data structure allows you
to store multiple values in each cell
while retaining the value
all collections are multi-valued columns
the maximum number of elements in a
collection is 64 000 which in practice
can be dozens or even hundreds
collections are designed to store a
small amount of data
the maximum size of an element is 64 kb
which in practice is much smaller than
the number of elements in collection
they are also retrieved in their
entirety
a collection column cannot be part of a
primary key a partition key or
clustering columns
you cannot nest a collection inside of
another collection
if you want to nest a collection inside
another
then you have to use the keyword frozen
more on this later
there are three collection types in
total
set
list
and map respectively
let's begin with the first collection
type set
it is a list that stores the typed
collection of unique values
it is stored on order but it gives back
the data in a sorted order
let's look at an example of set
here a user's table is created with an
id first name last name and a set of
email addresses
the data type is represented in angle
brackets so in this example text data
type is used
after that the values are inserted into
the table
here there are two email addresses
because it is common for a single user
to have two email addresses
list is like a set it groups and stores
values in a single cell
the difference between list and set is
that in a list the values does not have
to be unique and there can be duplicates
lists are stored in a particular order
and are accessed by an index
here's an example of how the users table
from the previous slide is altered to
insert a list of frequent destinations
first the table is added to list of text
data types
then the user cas one two three is
updated and berlin london and paris are
added to the list
list uses the set command to enter the
values for the respective collection
type
map is the last of our collection types
it allows us to enter values which are
in relation ship with one another in a
key value format
map is ordered by unique keys
both the key and the value have a
designated data type
map uses the set command to enter the
values for the map collection type
let's look at an example here
here the table users have again been
altered with a map called to do with the
data types of timestamp and text
then the user cast 123 is updated and a
map to-do list was added
the to-do list is a set of dates and
to-do items
in this case the user
cas123 is going to create a database on
january 1st
load and test the database the next day
and then a month after move the database
to production
here's another collection type frozen
if you want to nest collections inside
other collections you will have to use
the frozen keyword
without using frozen you cannot nest a
collection inside another collection
frozen allows us to serialize multiple
components into a single value
essentially frozen will turn that value
into a blob
if you want to update a single value in
the collection you can't use the frozen
keyword
now it's time to explore user defined
types popularly called udt
udt allows you to group together similar
fields of data that are both named and
typed
udts can include any supported data
types
including other collections and other
udts
multiple data fields can be attached
each named and typed to a single column
udts allow embedding of more complex
data within a single column adding
flexibility to your table and to your
data model
let's look at some examples
here a udt is created which has street
city
zip code and a set of phone numbers
now all these fields can make up a
single address
but in a relational world it is possible
for several users to have the same
address
so a new udt or full name is created
which has the user's first name and last
name now let's look at how the udt is
used in a table
first a users table is created which
includes name
set of direct reports and a map of
addresses in the name column the full
name udt is used
after that a set collection type with
full name udt is used to create a direct
reports column and finally address udt
is used in a map collection
in relational databases to find a query
you will have to first join these two
tables together but in cassandra's
denormalization
technique the address is embedded in a
single cell of the user's table
a counter is a data type where you can
have a column that stores a 64-bit
signed integer
they could be incremented or decremented
and the values are changed using the
update command
counters need to have a specially
dedicated table that can only have
primary key and counter columns
counters can lead to the duplicate data
in multiple tables
you can have more than one counter
column in your table
let's say we own a range that
specializes in cows and we want to count
the moo each cow makes
we're going to create a table called moo
count
it has the column name cow name which is
also the primary key of the table and
the moo count is the counter column
now to add to a moo count we will use
the update command to update the mu
counts table each time we hear a move
in this example we updated the mu count
to increment the value by 8 where the
cow name is betsy
upon completion of this module you will
be able to learn about the different
models in the data stacks modeling
methodology
upon completing this topic you will be
able to understand the purpose of
conceptual data model
and learn about the cardinality
attribute keys er model and relationship
keys
let's begin with the conceptual data
model
it is responsible for determining the
attributes of all the objects in your
domain and analyzing how they are
related
a conceptual model defines what a model
should contain
for example users comments videos
ratings etc
the purpose of a conceptual data model
is to identify what type of data is
contained in the model itself
from here you can extrapolate the
essential objects
and constraints that the data types
would additionally require
it is important that you capture all
different views of your model while
conceptualizing your data model
collaboration with other departments and
experts is the key
as a database architect it is critical
that your solutions serve your business
needs
you will not always be an expert on the
business domain and therefore it is
important to interact with non-technical
people to get hold of the details
both the technical and non-technical
members can share review and agree upon
the conceptual data model
business experts can then verify and
ensure that the conceptual data model is
correct and everyone is on the same page
collaboration between different
technical roles is also immensely
critical
apache cassandra requires database
administrators and developers to work
closely with each other
the conceptual model is a way of
bringing together the technical and
non-technical people to the same table
the conceptual data model offers an
abstract view of your domain
it is generally independent of
technology meaning that it does not
specify
what technology to use for example sql
or nosql
at this point it is not specific to any
database either
the term cardinality often refers to the
relationship between two entities in a
given data model
or in other words how many instances of
an entity are related to an instances of
another entity
cardinality tells how many times an
entity can or must participate in a
relationship
other possibilities are one to n
and one is to one
here the relationship between the video
entity and the actor entity is the
character name in the video and the
actors who played those characters
here m and n are the videos and actors
respectively
the videos feature actors
each video will have several actors and
each actor can participate in several
videos
attribute types are the fields that
store properties about an entity or
relationship
attributes or fields where we wish to
define our entity
for example we may want to store the
title and description of each video
actors of names which we can further
break down into other attributes like
first name and last name respectively
key attributes uniquely identify an
entity
two videos can have the same name or
description but the id is unique to a
single video
and the names are the unique key for
actors
let's look at the entity relationship
model
here we have an entity type the
relationship types and attribute types
and first we need to identify the entity
types
there are different entity types and
videos
these are things you're looking for to
find information
attribute types will look at actors and
define their first and last names
respectively
the relationship type looks at the
relationship between the video and the
actor
attributes can have multiple values and
we call these not surprisingly
multi-valued attributes
multi-valued attributes store multiple
values per attribute
one can refer to these attributes with a
double oval diagram around the attribute
types
for example one video can be an example
for more than one genre
now you will learn about the three
relationship keys one to one one to many
and many to many respectively
in the one-to-one relationship we use
either of the participating entity keys
in this example a movie can have one
defined date for its first showing
so this is an example of an one-to-one
key relationship
one to many relationships uses the
entity key on the many relationship side
here we have one user but we can upload
multiple videos
many-to-many relationship combines both
the entity keys
here many actors can be part of multiple
videos
weak entity types are entities that
cannot exist without a corresponding
strong entity on the other side
for example if the video vanishes or
disappears then the encoding will
disappear too
upon completing this topic you will be
able to
learn the concept of workflow and access
patterns
you will learn about application
workflow which describes how users will
navigate through the application
it also helps in determining which
queries will perform against an apache
cassandra database
every application has a particular
workflow
access patterns help us to determine how
the data is accessed
we also get to know what queries to run
first
for example when a user logs into a
website what are they going to click
what data are they going to use
what data are they going to read
how will a user go through a website
application
the workflow and access patterns must be
thought through before building the
application
think about how the application should
work and how users should use it
for example you may want one query to
run when a user logs into the site
this query will perhaps find the user
with a specified email address
once the user is in the site you may
want to run the second query to show the
latest videos uploaded to the site
you may want to
run a third query to verify the user's
login for them to access their account
details is indeed working or not
a fourth query can be used to find
videos uploaded by users with a known id
a fifth query can help you find a video
with a specified video id
these are just examples of popular
queries one can build into an
application
upon completing this topic you will be
able to
understand the mapping rules
explore a modeling approach to see how
mapping rules are applied
learn the concept of chaboko diagrams
understand the logical and physical udt
diagrams
and learn about the four data modeling
principles
at this point we have covered conceptual
data model and the application
workflow next we will look at how to
make a logical data model
to do this we have to map our conceptual
model to a logical model
now you will go through some basic rules
for query driven methodology
the mapping rules ensure that a logical
data model is correct
each query has a corresponding table
the tables are designed to allow queries
to execute properly
the tables will return the data in the
correct order
here are the five mapping rules to guide
a query driven
transition mapping rule 1
identify the entities and their
relationships
mapping rule 2
identify the equality search attributes
mapping rule 3 identify the inequality
search attributes
mapping rule 4 identify the ordering
attributes and
mapping rule 5 identify the key
attributes
create a table schema from the
conceptual data model for each query
apply the mapping rules in order
for this schema we're looking at videos
by user upload
therefore
mapping rule 1 identify your entities
and relationships
in this case we have a table named
videos uploaded by users
there is a relationship between two
uploads with users being one entity and
the videos being the other
mapping rule 2
identify your equality search attributes
in this case clearly equality is the
user id
mapping rule 3 identify the inequality
search attributes
in this case it is the uploaded
timestamp
mapping rule 4 identify the ordering
attribute
mapping rule 5
identify the key attributes needed to
guarantee uniqueness and minimality
here video id guarantees uniqueness
we have the conceptual data model on the
left and the access patterns on the
right
it is important to remember that our
application workflow had access patterns
based on the queries
which we wish to execute on our apache
cassandra database
this is an important part of the
application workflow
to get a logical data model we combine
the results of the conceptual data model
and the access patterns after combining
them some mapping rules and patterns are
applied
this logical model is described using a
chiboko diagram a diagram named after
artem chaboco who devised his method of
mapping to a logical data model
chaboco diagrams graphical
representations of cassandra database
schema design
they document the logical and physical
data models respectively
you already know your entities that is
the video and the key attributes
at the bottom query one is to find a
video with a specified video id
now if you look at the chiboko diagram
we can see that q1 leads into a table
which can satisfy this query we will get
into that in more detail but first we
have to understand some of the
terminologies used here
first and foremost this diagram looks
very similar to an application workflow
we have a queries which lead us into the
tables
we have the table diagrams which are
similar to the tables we have in our
cassandra database
we have the query list at the bottom
right
as you know queries are the king and the
queen while designing the cassandra data
model
and lastly we have our udt's which stand
for user-defined data types
these are a lot like cassandra tables
but without a primary key
and these can be nested into other
cassandra
tables on a logical level the cheboko
diagram shows the column names and
properties
on a physical level cheboko shows the
column data type
in order to move from the logical tables
to the physical tables we just need to
add column data type followed by a bit
of optimization if needed
here is an example of how a table is
broken down by column name data type and
type of column
as you can see in our table we have some
abstract column names on the left and
the corresponding descriptions on the
right
note that the notation on the left
corresponds to the description on the
right that is column 7 which is a list
is in square brackets
similarly column 8 a set is enclosed in
curly brackets
also a map like column 9 is in angular
brackets and so on
however the key thing to notice here is
that all these columns are followed by
their cql types which we have previously
studied
it is the physical types that makes the
table physical
we can now write our create table
commands using these column names and
their respective types into our database
also note that column one is a partition
key which is represented in the table as
k
similarly column 2 and 3 are clustering
columns which are represented by c
followed by an upward arrow or downward
arrow representing the ascending order
or descending order respectively
a static column is specified by s
secondary index column as idx and the
counter column as a plus plus
here you will learn about logical udt
diagrams in detail
udt is a data type and udts can be
nested within one another
for example there is an encoding column
in the videos table
this column represents our data is
stored in the database
there is more information about the data
than just simple text
hence it is encapsulated and it's stored
in the encoding udt
it has attributes of encoding height
width and bit rates
the same is true for actor name which
encapsulates the first name and last
name of the actor and stores it into the
udt column
if we want to have a single column to
store both first and last name or have
them stored differently it is important
to remember that udt can be very helpful
in such cases
here is the same diagram but with the
cql types explicitly specified
is a representation of the physical
layer udt diagrams
please notice how real cql types have
been specified for each column
this is a classic example of a logical
data model in the form of a detailed
chiboko diagram for the killer video
domain
take a moment and carefully observe this
diagram for all the concepts that we
have covered so far
we have queries which access our access
patterns are tables with different kinds
of data an application workflow that
links these queries to the tables and
are encoding udt defined
here are the four main principles of
cassandra data modeling
know your data
know your queries
nest data and duplicate data
we will look at each of these principles
in more detail
understanding the data is key to a
successful implementation of a database
a proper understanding of data provides
the understanding to organize the data
as well
as we have seen space and time are often
are primary concerns while data modeling
in cassandra we sacrifice space in order
to reduce time
hence organization of data is of utmost
importance
the conceptual data model provides us
with the data capturing information
once we define what is to be stored we
move on to create a database
this not only helps in successful
organization but also helps in
preserving the properties of the data
that is required
part of understanding the data requires
understanding a primary key as well
to recall primary keys take care of two
essential things uniqueness and
satisfying queries
entity and relationship keys affect the
table primary keys
primary key uniquely identifies a row
entity and a relationship
let's look at the following tables for
example
the video tables as video id as its
primary key
here the primary key makes no attempt at
organizing the data so as to satisfy
queries at later stages
on the other hand the table videos by
user as a primary key along with
clustering columns which specify
ordering in order to help with queries
that result in returning the results in
a specified order
the relationship cardinalities as well
as the data cardinality are very
important when it comes to data modeling
data cardinality helps in selecting an
efficient partition key whereas the
relationship cardinality helps in
satisfying the queries
queries are the center of data modeling
in cassandra and captured by the
application workflow models
each entity is created with queries in
mind
in cassandra it's always better to
reduce the number of partitions that are
to be read for a query result
table schema also changes if the queries
are changed
to achieve this it is extremely
important to clearly understand the kind
of data required out of the read
operations
single partition per query is the most
efficient access pattern
entities in cassandra are designed in
such a way that queries can generate the
results with the minimum number of reads
ideally the data should be organized in
such a way that each query can retrieve
the results from a single partitioned
search
partition can be single row or multi-row
respectively
in this example if we want to query for
a particular partition we can give the
partition key
then the node having the partition is
determined and the data is retrieved by
the node and returned to us
no additional filtering or searching the
entire cluster is required
however there are cases when multiple
partitions have to be accessed to
retrieve the results and although this
is a less efficient way of doing things
in cassandra it is acceptable to some
extent as long as these kind of queries
are limited in number
however the strict anti-pattern that has
to be avoided at all costs is asking the
database to perform a linear search
through all the partitions of all the
tables to fetch the result for a
particular query
since most of the data is stored in
distributed nodes it is highly
inefficient to go through all the data
stored at multiple locations and it
defeats the whole purpose of having a
horizontally scaled database
after completing this topic you will be
able to learn the concept of data
nesting and explore the three ways of
nesting data
until now we've talked about creating a
logical data model by combining the
results of a conceptual data model and
accessing the pattern of application
workflow by applying mapping rules and
patterns
let's now create a logical data model
containing tables for each query
capturing entities and relationships
from the conceptual model
the working rule with apache cassandra
is to group as much data as possible on
disk
this grouping of data is referred to as
nesting of data and is the main data
modeling technique for a cassandra data
model
nesting helps in organizing multiple
data entities into a single partition
and it also helps support partition per
query during data access
in cassandra queries are the king and
the queen
schemas are often driven through these
application queries
there are three main ways of nesting
data in cassandra
these are clustering columns collection
columns and user defined type
columns
clustering columns are the primary data
nesting mechanisms
look at the actors by video table on the
right
we apply a query to filter by video id
but we nest the actors by their actor
name and the character name using
clustering columns
the partition key identifies the entity
that other entities nest into while the
clustering columns identify the nested
entities
when a table has multiple clustering
column the data is stored in a nested
sorted order
multiple clustering columns implement
multi-level nesting
in the given example actors are
identified by videos using clustering
columns
udts are a secondary mechanism for
nesting data
usually this occurs when there is a
one-to-one relationship
you also have lists of maps
or your choice of user-defined types
within a single column
working with udts is much easier than
working with multiple collection columns
for example we turn videos into a video
type udt with id title description and
other parameters
then we put all those videos in a
collection column in the videos by user
table
table videos by user tests all videos as
a collection in the videos column with
the video underscore type type
partition per query and data nesting may
result in data duplication
in relational data models the tables are
joined as we read the data
in cassandra however instead of wasting
time on reads the data is taken and
returned to the client application
for example we have three tables that
represent the video's object videos by
actor videos by genre and videos by tag
this duplicates data across tables
partitions and rows
that means every time we want to store a
new video we have to write the record
into each one of these tables to keep
them in sync
upon completing this topic you will be
able to
learn how to use data types in a table
understand the ways to load data into
the table
and explore some of the features of cql
copy
here's our data modeling methodology
again
we've created our conceptual model and
our application workflow
we've also applied the mapping rules
created a logical data model
and now it's time for us to create our
physical data model
to make a physical model add data types
to each column of a logical model
physical models also
optimize efficiency and performance
ensuring that the partition sizes won't
grow too large
and will return the queries quickly
here we have a logical version of
commons by user and a physical version
of comments by user
as you can see the physical version of
cql data types like
user id is uuid
posted timestamp is of time stamp data
type
video id is of time uuid data type
comment title and type is of text
respectively
tags is a set of text
and lastly
preview thumbnails is defined as a map
now we will use these data types in
creating a table
we already saw how to use the data types
in the table in theory
to better understand the physical data
model it's time to demonstrate it with
an example
creating a table could cause a lot of
problems if the tables aren't configured
correctly
the first challenge is creating a
partition that is way too large
there are many other challenges that are
related to optimization
now we have data types which we have
added in the previous topic
now let's create a table using the cql
create table statement
in this example we've created a table of
comments by user
the field in the table are everything
that we saw on the previous slide in the
physical version of the table the user
id is uuid
and the posted timestamp is a timestamp
and all the other data types that we saw
earlier
once the table is created the user may
want to insert data into it
there can be two types of users
a new user and an existing user
if it's a new application then users
will use your site and insert the data
for you
but if you're migrating from an existing
database then it may take a few ways to
get the data into the table
first is the copy command which can
leverage cql copy in cql and has a value
of inserting approximately 2 million
values into the database
second is the ss table loader which is
used when migrating from one cluster to
another
and lastly there is spark for data
loading which has a lot of options but
does not require a working knowledge of
spark
here are some basic sql copy features
copy 2 exports data from a table to a
csv file
copy from imports data to a table from a
csv file in sql copy the process
verifies the primary key and updates the
existing records accordingly
if the header is false it specifies that
the fields are imported in a
deterministic
order
when column names are specified in the
table then the fields are imported in
that order
if any field is missing or empty it is
set to null
source cannot have more fields than the
target table but surely can have less
number of fields than the target table
so let's look at an example of basic
data loading with cql copy
this is a good method to use and to get
started
we will import the data in column 1
column 2 and column 3 from the csv file
table 1 data.csv
when header is equal to true
welcome to module 4 cassandra practical
application
we're going to help you start your own
cassandra as a service db on a cloud
provider of your choice
cassandra as a service is named astrodb
and is provided by datastax
upon completion of this module you will
be able to
create your own astrodb instance
and perform the workshops
upon completing this lesson you will be
able to perform the workshop related to
this course
earlier we learnt about different apis
to connect to our astrodb like the
document api graphql api and the rest
api
all of these apis are part of a project
called stargate
stargate is built into astrodb for your
convenience
if you would like to learn more about
what stargate is how it works how you
can get involved in the open source
project please go to stargate.io
for more information
for an in-depth understanding of how it
all works and how you can utilize target
your advantage
view the workshop video on youtube
created by the data stacks developer
advocates
scan the qr code to go to the video or
copy the link and paste it in your
preferred browser
another option for your astra db is to
build a to do app using the rest api
python and node.js respectively
this is an example react to do
application built using a datastax astra
fee free tier database
for an in-depth understanding of how it
all works
view the workshop video on youtube
created by the datastax developer
advocates
scan the qr code to go to the video or
copy the link and paste it in your
preferred browser
in this example we discover a fully
reactive version of the spring pet
clinic application using spring web flux
this example is considered an
intermediate level application for
developers to build on astra db
for an in-depth understanding of how it
all works view the workshop video on
youtube created by the data stacks
developer advocates
scan the qr code to go to the video or
copy the link and paste it in your
preferred browser
earlier in this course we carried out
some basic data modeling to understand
how cassandra can best be built and
deployed
if you wanted to do a deeper dive into a
more advanced data modeling for your app
we also have a workshop available for
you to view on youtube from the data
stacks developer advocates
once again scan the qr code to go to the
video or copy the link and paste it in
your preferred browser
throughout this course we had mentioned
using spark for specific functions on
astra db including data loading and
connecting
we also wanted to provide you with a
workshop for you to view if you would
like to get a more in-depth
understanding of how it all works and
how you can utilize spark to your
advantage on youtube again created by
the developer advocates of data stacks
scan the qr code to go to the video or
feel free to copy the link and paste it
in your preferred browser